this is Startalk so let's go with Nelson
stop okay from Facebook that's a pretty
decent question I like you know let's
just sound so surprised our listeners
are very sophisticated Bunch
you know what I just realized that that
I did sound that way I just wanted let
it go I would have been remiss so lean
right okay so Melton from facebook says
this have NASA's zero gravity
experiments had any useful breakthroughs
which better our society so I assume
that Nelson means outside of space
travel where of course it is directly
applicable but here on earth do those
zero gravity experiments do anything for
us down here who are living in gravity
I'd say there's one thing specifically
they have led to research in bone health
really yeah so these modern bone
medicines wouldn't probably they
probably wouldn't be the way they are
without all these discoveries made in
zero or so-called microgravity where
people have very low gravity your bones
you know you look at a skeleton right
there in the museum let's say of
American Museum of Natural History for
example okay and they are solid they
look like rocks but bones get flecks
that are alive and if you stop putting a
load on them they get weak and this is
one of the things they discovered about
astronauts in space for a long time or
even a medium amount of time they lost
their bones their calcium they would
urinate it away is that because the body
just realizes well there's no need
i I'm not I'm not using this I don't
need it yes and when you say realizes
reactions though it lies yeah yes that's
why nine scientific way of saying the
body reacts bottle reacts yeah and so
did now people take pills to keep their
bones going and so they have speculated
people who are in this world speculate
that you could go to Mars
in nearly zero gravity just by taking
the right drugs you could keep your
bones so this is affecting health on
earth the
thing we've learned so much about
physics writ large by watching people
bounce around in microgravity oh really
now you just I mean you just watch how
things happen you learn about torques
and reactions sort of classical physics
it's beautiful thing beautiful thing
nice all right
so and do any of those observations
especially when it comes to watching
objects or people bounce around in
zero-g does that do anything in any
particular industry like I'm thinking
maybe the automobile industry might be
able to you know go ahead to things
people all dreamt of was new alloys okay
of metal right would only be fabric able
I'm a coin the adjective in space or in
nearly zero gravity that hasn't been
panned out or alloyed out and then the
other one was sophisticated drug
molecules that you could create more
easily in zero gravity than you could
create on earth and while that sounds
reasonable when you're working a
molecular level gravity isn't the main
thing and sort of viscosity just
stickiness of molecules or overwhelms
the gravitational effect with that set
who knows what lies ahead what discovery
is yet to be made and they study spite
they we people astronauts study spiders
who are still able to capture pet prey
even though there's zero grub even in
zero gravity they have trouble spinning
webs they have trouble spinning webs but
they're able dumb how it can still with
it's a learning curve or it's a learning
process
spider jumps and misses butter just
jumps and gets so there's something
going on spider brain-wise right
compensating for zero gravity so what
you and I think with our inner ears and
how we roll or keep from rolling is that
we think this part you might project
that on spiders and other arthropods but
they got something else going on there's
something else going on and so you
wouldn't really learn that without
experiments in zero gravity or near zero
gravity well that's great so zero
gravity there you have it Nelson doing a
eight things for us as a society and for
spiders as well for example for example
but you know spider-man one of the
things that he can do he can do whatever
a spider can this is true he can been a
web anything odd-eyes catches thieves
just like fly look out here comes the
spider-man